[Music]
diego is with us in
phoenix arizona hi diego welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how you doing thank you for
taking my call sure what's up first time
caller first time listener honestly i
just started listening to you so it's
probably about
sunday oh wow okay i'm honored how can i
help you
um
i mean about a hundred thousand dollars
in debt
and
i have a i have i purchased a home about
in 2016
and i purchased it with my
brother-in-law and him and his wife
lived with me my wife and my daughter
and i don't know it's just been getting
too much for me already i just want to
do my own thing with my family
and
just leave us on our own already
but
part of that hundred thousand dollars
i've been dead
is to him
uh he's been helping us a lot
um he's he has this he has his job he's
the owner
of his own company he makes about over a
hundred a year over a hundred thousand a
year i i just started truck driving
and i'm barely making uh i just started
making 50 000 a year 51 000 a year about
two months ago
before that i was a phlebotomist and
just making
30 000 a year
and i don't know what would you
recommend having us just sell the house
and give him his part of
whatever we profited of it and then
whatever i've profited just pay him off
and pay all my debt off and
start fresh with my family and try to
try to
get into another house or or what would
you recommend me doing
well if you did all that you won't get
another house you got to get out of debt
first and you'd be so you'd be in a
rental
um so the the home you're living in that
you own with him
uh is there a mortgage on it
yes there's a mortgage are you on the
100
yes
um i was the one that got the loan
me and my wife my wife doesn't work so
i'm doing i'm doing the one that has
income at home yeah for us okay how much
do you owe your brother-in-law
i owe him about
almost 15 000.
okay what's the other 85 000 that you
have in debt
uh about 40
40 um 40 at school from because i was
good like i said i'm a phlebotomist but
i was going to school to be a laboratory
tech and i stopped going just for
different reasons and i became a
phlebotomist
and i never went back to school
so i just pretty much have a semester
left before okay so you got 40k in
student loans 15 to your brother-in-law
what's the rest of it
and then um about 10 000 in credit cards
and then 35 000 or so in a in a vehicle
okay
on a single car you owe 35 dollars
yeah it's a brand new car mo does your
wife work outside the home
no she's just a stay-at-home mom okay
well when you make 51 000 a year a 35
000 car loan is what's called insanity
yeah yeah you gotta sell this car
okay it's ridiculous it's killing you
you got a 700 car payment don't you
600 yeah almost like i've done this
before
yeah and so um
man oh man yeah you're no wonder you're
you're drowning here so what is the
house that you're living in what's the
house you're living in worth
well i've just looked it up on google
and on zillow and stuff like that and
it's showing about 300 and
it was like 370 000 already and we only
owe 175.
okay so there's about 100 equity and
there's about 100 equity in there and
when you're selling your car you could
be debt free and have a little money in
your pocket living in an apartment
or a rental house
yes making 51 000 a year and he you'd be
debt-free you know you would pay him
back and you'd be rid of the vehicle
yeah yeah and and that's just for the
next three months by march i should be
because like i said i just started truck
driving and the company i'm at i'm like
a junior driver so within three to four
months i might be making 62 000. yeah
still doesn't work for a 35 000 car loan
yeah that's still a car is out of
control so it's gone it's got to go
now so uh
when you guys bought the house together
did you have an agreement
on at what point this would end
no
honestly
and
you thought you thought you would live
with him until you're 80.
not me honestly um my my brother-in-law
his wife is my wife's older sister yeah
and so you thought you were all of you
you didn't have an end to date to this
or a way of getting out of this deal you
guys just signed up and thought you were
going to live there forever
until for now so i don't know who knows
when yeah well i know when next week
so yeah you guys need to sell it
sell it yeah so that you can get out of
debt
and so that you can pay him back and so
your family can be on your own in
renting
you're broke yeah because that's
me it's me my always biggest um
arguments all the time that there's no
money no matter how much we do we're
still always in bed and more and more
and more and like exactly
and that's what that's due to two things
due to two things you have you have a
house loan that you can't afford in a
car loan that you can't afford and
you've had some job problems but now you
got the job thing straightened out
yep okay so if we get the income going
and we got the out go the spending going
down because we get rid of this house
deal and we get rid of this car
suddenly you're gonna have a great life
can you imagine what it'd be like to
have no payments in the world and be
renting
yeah that can be yours
sell the car sell the house
okay let me see my next version which is
renting my as i said we want to do stuff
on our own
my parents own a little ranch they have
a guest house in the back like a town
private house is not connected to the
main house or nothing it's a one bedroom
one bath
small living room how many kids have you
got would you
i just have a little four-year-old
daughter she's gonna be foreign i don't
think this is probably gonna work
because i don't think your wife's gonna
be real thrilled with this
yeah she's not that's [ __ ] yeah i
think
if you have no doubt
listen listen if you have no debt no car
payment
no house payment
and you rent something conservatively
you guys can spend the next two years
getting on your feet and saving up a
down payment and buying a home
okay but you're gonna have to clean up
the dead gum mess to get started you're
under water right now you've got a car
that's a mess you got a house that's a
mess you got a living situation that's
untenable and so you're exactly right i
mean you know what to do you just wanted
me to tell you
sell the car sell the house pay off your
brother-in-law pay off your student loan
pay off your credit cards cut them up
never have another car payment again
never have another credit card again
rent something inexpensive get yourself
on a budget and turn things around
you can do all of this and i can show
you how i'll show you how to do every
bit of it
so hang on i'll have laura send you a
copy of the book the total money
makeover and show you and your wife
exactly what to do and if you like that
and really want to get into it you can
get into financial peace university but
for right now i'll send you that book
and get you started